ما أضر الحمامة بالدولة التي لا مفر منها
في ندوة الذرة - مينا وضعناها
في الجهاز حوالي الساعة 1 بعد الظهر
الاحد 48 ساعة شكل الاثنين
ها نحن نسألني إذا كنت
كانوا يستخدمون
البستنة المنزلية و arleen thibault
ويلش ودونالد ما لا يقل عن ثلاثة إلى أربعة
ساعات من انتظار أحد أبناء هذه الجزر
هي هدايا أعراض ليست كذلك
حسنًا ، هم مرضى يصطفون في الطابور
لمدة أربع ساعات عندما تكون كذلك
مريض
من الصعب أن يكون لديك تعاطف مع
الشخصية الأمر معقد بعض الشيء
فجأة نقوم بالكثير
العدوانية تريد حقًا أن تقطع الأميال و
لدي مشبك orthez والجانب الذي أنت عليه
بعض تشارلز بيدو nîmes ويجب
تخيل تحية كل شيء على ما يرام أنا
ذهبنا في إجازة وكنا بداخلها
كعكة عالية مع أربع فتيات هناك
لمن لديه اللقطة الفارغة ومن هو
مريض في هذه اللحظة وفجأة أنا
يبدأ في الحصول على أعراض لذا أ
زعيم الضغط للحصول عليه لذلك سأفعل
للحصول على اختبار للسلامة لدي
وجبة عائلية في نهاية هذا الأسبوع كل شيء
سنام العالم يتم اختباره من أجل جوز الهند
فارغة لذا يجب التأكد من الخلف
سلامة المصابين بالربو
لدينا أشخاص لديهم حساسية
النساء معا لذلك بالنسبة لي هو
من المهم أن تصطف هنا الأسر
القليل هو تسمية موتون تمادا
المرض في عد توبا ليسنر و
صور حسية بشغف ريبراك
بالشرور التي تقوض الأرنب مالوني
الديدان المكسورة والهيمالايا في كندا
لا شيء مثل هذا الهراء هناك أديما جورونا
استبدال ماكون ليون نحن تقريبا
حوالي ستين شخصًا
يتم اختبارها لكل ساعة وظيفة تحافظ
هذا الرقم هنا نقوم بالحساب
تم اختبار 3500 شخص في الأسبوع
هذا هو الهدف الذي يبدو واقعيا بالنسبة لـ
فيما يتعلق بما استطعنا معرفته
الأيام الأولى
الأجانب lehto jade osiwa إلقاء اللوم عليه
لوسائل الإعلام